foreign
starts off this hour hi Tiffany how are
you
hi
um thank you so much for taking my call
I'm sorry I'm a little nervous it's okay
what's up
um I'm an office manager for a small
construction company and
um one of the owners out of the two has
been using a secret credit card and
purchasing a lot of purchase personal
stuff with it and then using the
company's checking to pay off the
balance each month I'm just kind of
curious is it only
um morally wrong if I don't say anything
to the owner other owner or um
is it not my um none of my business to
be passing information along
so let me help you with how you answer a
business ethics question
treat other people
like you'd want to be treated
so reverse it
you own a construction company and you
have an employee
who knows that there is a thief
inside the business
what would you expect that employee to
do ethically
um definitely tell me that my concern is
I feel like if I say something I'll lose
my job but if I don't say something I
don't say something and I found out and
you worked for me I would fire you
okay for not telling me why why would
you lose your job foretelling
the other guys got more power than the
other than the guy she's telling they're
they're equal Partners but um one is
kind of Silent he's he he's a wimp goes
kind of but um yeah
um I just the lion is this thief and the
wimp
is the guy losing the money
you need to get out of there don't you
yeah I just started listening to you
guys about a week ago and um I'm so I'm
only in baby step one I've got 98 000 in
debt how old are you
33. what do you make oh
uh currently 56 with um this job and I
just got a part-time job what do you
make there at the thief place
50. okay and how long have you been
there
um about three years okay sometimes
doing the right thing is painful in the
short term it is never painful in the
long term
100 of the time that you don't take care
of this it's going to cause you problems
later
tell the the weak leader that this other
guy is basically stealing money do you
think there's a chance that he'll just
be like uh yeah big deal do you think
that he won't care
I think he'll blame me for not I guess
watching more closely and not giving him
a heads up I mean everything I've always
been going on
um it's just gotten progressively worse
over the past and what I asked I asked
how long he's been stealing
uh probably since I started which is how
long
about three years
um but it hasn't been to this level like
um
I stealing has levels but at no point is
it okay
so you're concerned because you've
noticed this for three years and you
haven't said anything but now you're
like I gotta say something and you're
afraid that the other guy is going to go
hey why didn't you say something sooner
Tiffany you're going to lose your job
you're gonna lose your job because you
didn't take care of this when you should
have
the first time you saw it you should
have walked in his office the other
guy's office and said look I don't know
what to do with this information but if
the roles were reversed I would want to
know and I'm going to leave the
information with you to do with what you
want but it's not going to be on me I'm
not keeping secrets for thieves
I want to leave a year ago and I figured
that um once I left that somebody else
would see it's always no it's honey this
is on your watch
okay you have to report the thief and
you have to look for a job
number one even if they want to keep you
you don't want to work there anymore
that's true
okay this is a messed up toxic
environment yeah
a strong thief and a weak need partner
this is not and you're stuck in the
middle and didn't know what to do and
therefore didn't do the right thing yeah
that's a warning sign when when you're
in a situation like that and you can't
you don't feel you'll be supported or if
for doing the right thing that's a
problem too yeah it's not even even if
the guy even if they rise up and have a
big Clash over it and the guy we're
calling the weak leader is you're going
to stand up to the other guy surprise he
stood up okay we're all surprised we're
all shocked uh but even then you're not
going to come out of this you've known
this for three years
you don't come out looking good because
you didn't bring it up earlier yeah it
makes it look like you're part of it
yeah that's what I was concerned about
that I look like the
hiding it is not going to fix that
okay so go get a job this week walk in
and tell the guy I should have told you
three years ago I'm sorry I didn't I
goofed I let you down I'm out of here
I'm not gonna work in a place like this
this guy's stealing from you
um I do have two interviews this week
but it's significantly like ten dollars
less an hour do I just suck it up and
take them and work multiple jobs until I
find something yep get something yep
something's better than nothing and then
otherwise every day you're going in
there you are a liar
oh okay you can't be that that's not who
you are that's why you called us because
it's tearing your guts yeah it's eating
you up
you're not that person you're not that
person and you can't for the past year
yes hello yeah hello John John Maxwell
John deloney says anxiety is a fire
alarm warning you that there's a problem
well guess what there's a problem of
course you're going to have anxiety in a
situation where you're protecting a
thief and you're not a thief and you're
not a liar by Nature
of course you're going to have anxiety
so hey we're going to save you a bunch
of money we're getting rid of your
anxiety pills because we're getting this
job you're going to feel so much better
Tiffany when you get out of there you
don't feel like you don't feel clean
like you took a shower
yeah I'm just concerned too about like
financially because I only have 500 in
my emergency fund and I've got so much
debt well you've got these jobs lined up
you don't have a choice
okay you're about to get fired
as soon as they find this they're going
to blame it on you if you don't bring it
up
because Mr lion that's the thief is
going to have a story that somehow well
Tiffany's known about it we all thought
it was all okay what's your problem well
the problem is you're a freaking Thief
that's my problem but nobody stands up
to this guy so you got to get out of
there girl
this is bad news and next time you're
presented with an Ethics problem don't
wait three years to fix it and chew on
anxiety pills and wonder why you got
anxiety
you step into the ethics stuff face up
so team member at Ramsey knows another
team member stealing doesn't tell me I
discover it they're both gone
I'm not a big old meanie but I can't
trust either one of them and trust is an
essential part of a relationship